qu'est-ce qui se passe parce que là
Gisèle
la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle le débat sur le thème quelle
place donner aux acteurs du
médico-social dans l'organisation des
soins de demain sur nos territoires
demande du groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat madame
Patricia schininger pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants chers
collègues vous avez la parole pour 8
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la crise sanitaire a
exerce B les faiblesses de l'hôpital
public dont le manque de Lille ne
constitue que la face émergée de
l'iceberg
nous en avons parlé longuement lors de
notre débat mardi les difficultés
éprouvées au plus fort de la crise par
le secteur sanitaire pour répondre à la
demande à la demande de soins témoigne
de la défaillance plus large à laquelle
fait face comme tant d'autres pays
voisins notre système de santé la nation
a pu à cette occasion témoigner sa
reconnaissance au personnel soignants
hospitaliers en première ligne face à la
covid-19 alors côté les personnels des
établissements médico-sociaux ce sont
également mobilisés pour maintenir la
continuité du lien et des
accompagnements de la situation
qui menaçait de mettre gravement en
péril ils ont été une centraux pour
toute notre système de soins sanitaires
et sociaux si chers à nos valeurs et à
notre histoire la crise sanitaire a
suscité dans l'urgence des solidarités
nouvelles et à encourager la mise en
oeuvre de prise en charge innovantes
c'est dans les crises que nous nous
sommes les plus créatif que les
barrières s'abaissent et que les
collaborations se lient une fois encore
la pandémie nous a démontré la véracité
de cette notion à l'heure de tirer les
enseignements de la crise sanitaire et
au moment où il nous faut repenser
l'organisation des soins pour la rendre
plus efficace avec le groupe RDPI nous
avons jugé pertinent de nous interroger
sur la place que pourrait occuper les
acteurs du médico-social dans cette
nouvelle organisation des soins de
demain trop souvent le regard inquiet se
porte sur l'hôpital et sur la médecine
de ville comme unique garant de la
continuité des soins ils sont essentiels
c'est certain et notre groupe sera dans
les mois prochains défendre avec vigueur
leur rôle mais ils ne sont pas les seuls
ils ne sont pas les seuls pour résoudre
le problème grandissant des zones sous
dotées ils ne sont pas les uniques
relaient pour assurer la prévention le
secteur du médico-social et tous les
professionnels qui incluent sont au cœur
de notre politique du soin dans toute sa
pluralité et sa complexité ces acteurs
interviennent dans des domaines variés
tels que celui de l'enfance du plus
grand âge du
handicap de la Protection Maternelle et
Infantile auprès de personnes en grande
difficulté sociale et de santé ou encore
dans le cadre de la protection des
majeurs il occupe un rôle déterminant
dans notre société un rôle économique en
libérant du temps pour les aidants
salariés ou encore en prévenant la
désertification pardon des insertions
professionnelles des personnels
fragilisés par le handicap ou la maladie
ils ont bien sûr un rôle social de
maintien du lien de solidarité dont la
nécessité a été
exacerbée durant la crise alors que les
attentes vis-à-vis de ces personnels
sont fortes et qu'ils doivent assurer la
prise en charge de la précarité il se
sentent parfois eux-mêmes précaires
aussi comme l'hôpital le secteur
médico-social est en proie à des
difficultés de recrutement je tiens ici
à souligner l'effort consenti par le
gouvernement pour un million de
professionnels de ces secteurs qui ont
été revalorisés parmi eux les
professionnels médical des professions
de soins et pour certains secteurs comme
celui du grand âge les professionnels de
l'accompagnement cette reconnaissance
accordée dans le cadre du Ségur a été
élargi également aux professionnels
socio-éducatif dans tous les
établissements et services du handicap
de la protection de l'enfance de
l'insertion ou encore de l'hébergement
s'adressant à un public de personnes par
définition vulnérable et dépendante les
acteurs des médicaments sociales
occupent une position stratégique dans
l'organisation du soin et sont
susceptibles d'intervenir à des étapes
clés de la prise en charge médicale
d'éventuelles
face au vieillissement de la population
et un nombre croissant de personnes
âgées de plus en plus dépendantes
garantir à celle-ci une prise en charge
adaptée à leur état selon leur degré
d'autonomie permettrait en effet de
libérer du temps médical il s'agit de
favoriser le maintien à domicile des
personnes légèrement dépendantes grâce
d'une part au renforcement de l'aide à
2016 et d'autre part au financement de
l'adaptation des logements dans nos
territoires au syndical parfois nous
manquons de structures dédiées et mon
collègue Théophile le rappellera les
professionnels du médico-social peuvent
aussi être le déroulés à domicile pour
assurer en France que vieillir n'est pas
le signe d'une finalité mais d'un
nouveau chapitre dans le même temps pour
accueillir des personnels de plus en
plus dépendants les EHPAD doivent être
remédicalisés garantir une prise en
charge adaptée à nos aînés c'est
permettre de mieux vieillir et c'est
encore du temps médical que l'on libère
je pense aussi à nos enfants dont les
problématiques d'une santé mentale se
font de plus en plus inquiétantes nos
éducateurs spécialisés connaissent les
jeunes ils pourront être des garants
d'un diagnostic précoce et ils sont
utiles Le Mans formés à ces enjeux je
pense encore à nos concitoys nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap
dont l'inclusion dépend aussi de la
place donnée aux professionnels du
médico-social dans toutes nos structures
de celles dédiées à l'éducation autant
que celle l'emploi aussi nous faut-il
aimer déjà imaginer de nouvelles formes
d'organisation de soins afin d'être
demain en capacité de proposer dans les
territoires une offre de son adaptés aux
besoins qui sont exprimés pensez
organiser des soins de demain en
collaboration avec les acteurs de nos
territoires ces données à chacun toute
sa place l'opportunité pour les élus
locaux de trouver résolution aux enjeux
de terrain qu'ils connaissent si bien
laissé aux nouvelles générations de
professionnels des possibilités
novatrices pour collaborer ensemble vers
un vivre ensemble inclusif et protecteur
alors mes chers collègues le sujet qui
nous a mis aujourd'hui est un vin et
vaste mais il existe je crois toujours
dans les questions d'ampleur des
solutions concrètes et dans les grands
débats des petites victoires madame la
ministre je sais votre attachement à ce
sujet d'organisation des soins et de
parvenir concrètement à assurer que
notre modèle de soins et
d'accompagnement cher à notre culture
française perdure pour tous
nos concitoyens je vous remercie d'être
aujourd'hui avec nous pour échanger
ensemble pendant ce temps dédié j'espère
que chacun pourra ici apporter une
vision nouvelle enrichie par nos
expériences variées qui saura être force
de proposition pour l'avenir je vous
remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
Agnès Firmin le Bodo ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé
madame la présidente mesdames
messenatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
souhaite tout d'abord remercier le
groupe rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants d'avoir
inscrit ce débat à l'ordre du jour de
votre assemblée je profite de la tenue
de ce débat pour saluer les quelques 11
millions de nos concitoyens engagés qui
viennent en aide chaque jour aux
personnes en perte d'autonomie dans
notre pays puisque le 6 octobre est en
effet comme vous le savez la Journée
nationale des aidants ils ont tout notre
respect et méritent une attention
constante
quelle place donner aux acteurs du
médico-social dans l'organisation des
soins de demain sur nos territoires je
vous redire le plaisir qui est le mien
d'intervenir devant vous à ce sujet qui
soulève des enjeux cruciaux pour
l'avenir de notre système de santé
tentant matière d'égalité d'accès à la
santé sur le territoire que
d'attractivité des métiers du
médico-social avant de parler de demain
ce débat mérite un mot sur IR avec un
constat la crise sanitaire qui a été une
épreuve collective a notamment mis en
exerne combien notre système de soins a
besoin de dépasser l'hospitalocentrisme
pour aller vers des coopérations
territoriales en tracteur du soin et du
médico-social
le gouvernement tire toutes les leçons
de ce constat et c'est pourquoi le sujet
de l'organisation territoriale des soins
est au cœur de mon ministère en lien
avec mes collègues François Braun
Jean-Christophe combe et Geneviève
Darius sec
un mot et quelques chiffres seront
aujourd'hui également au moment où le
Parlement s'apprête à examiner le PLFSS
en 2023 l'objectif global de dépenses au
moment très respectivement de 5,1 et 5,2
% pour la prise en charge des personnes
âgées et des personnes vivant avec un
handicap pour atteindre 30 milliards ce
sont ainsi près de 1,5 milliards de
financement supplémentaires consacré au
secteur médico-social l'année prochaine
c'est un signe fort de l'engagement que
nous souhaitons avoir dans ce domaine
en particulier le sujet du Bien Vieillir
constituera un axe central de notre
action gouvernementale il s'agit
notamment d'assurer le virage
domiciliaire c'est-à-dire permettre à
nos concitoyens de disposer de solutions
de maintien à domicile ou de prise en
charge dans des structures adaptées à la
diversité de leur situation c'est au
centre de notre stratégie de prévention
de la perte d'autonomie et de la lutte
contre la dépendance
ces sujets seront d'ailleurs au cœur du
CNR comme vous le savez suite à
l'installation du Conseil national de la
refondation par le Président de la
République les secteurs de la santé et
des solidarités font l'objet de
déclinaisons thématique dédiée elle vise
à concerter largement avec l'ensemble
des acteurs pour faire émerger les
solutions concrètes pragmatiques et
adaptées aux besoins des territoires
la crise agit comme un révélateur de nos
faiblesses mais aussi comme un
formidable catalyseur en matière
d'innovation technologique et
organisationnelle partout sur le
territoire des organisations nouvelles
ont été déployées des freins historiques
ont été levés et des solutions locales
ont été trouvées en matière d'aller vers
d'accompagnement et de prise en charge
c'est cet état d'esprit que nous
souhaitons conserver et promouvoir dans
le cadre de ce CNR pour construire avec
l'ensemble des partis prenantes locales
et nationales la santé de demain dans
une logique de confiance de coopération
et de subsidiarité
pour revenir aux enjeux meubles du débat
je voudrais rappeler que le secteur
médico-social à d'ores et déjà une place
essentielle dans l'organisation actuelle
des soins je suis convaincu que dans un
avenir proche la coopération renforcée
entre le sanitaire et le médico-social
constituera un enjeu clé et pour un
apporter des solutions concrètes aux
besoins exprimés par nos concitoyens il
nous faut donc réinventer la place des
acteurs du secteur médico-social dans
l'organisation territoriale du soin au
sens du Caire aujourd'hui des enjeux de
sensibilisation de formation de
coordination d'accompagnement des
professionnels de santé de prévention
sur l'autonomie notamment
réinventer la place des acteurs du
secteur du médico-social dans
l'organisation territoriale des soins
c'est aussi bien entendu parler de
l'avenir des métiers de ce secteur qui
est aujourd'hui le quatrième pourvoyeur
d'emploi dans notre pays et qui s'est
fortement mobilisé pendant la crise
sanitaire
[Musique]
néanmoins les tensions qui subsistent
sur les métiers de l'accompagnement de
ce résultat aux enjeux légitimes de
rémunération il nous faut toujours aller
plus loin pour renforcer l'attractivité
de ces métiers améliorer les conditions
de travail accompagner la construction
de parcours et de carrière ou encore
rénover la formation c'est aussi l'objet
de notre débat ce jour aussi l'action ou
du gouvernement en faveur de
l'attractivité des métiers de
l'autonomie et guidé par deux grands
principes qui vont nous permettre de
préparer cet avenir d'une part
simplifier et fluidifier parce qu'il
nous faut faciliter les démarches à
celles et ceux qui veulent s'engager
dans ces filières et d'autre part
reconnaître et valoriser parce que ces
métiers doivent pouvoir susciter des
vocations et trouver leur juste place au
sein de notre société
ces principes sont traduits par des
mesures concrètes dans le PLFSS je pense
à l'instauration des deux heures
hebdomadaires consacrées aux liens
social auprès de nos aînés à la
transformation des EHPAD à la création
de nouvelles places de Siad ou encore
aux mesures en faveur de l'amélioration
de l'accès à la santé mais je voudrais
surtout mettre en avant le changement de
méthode pour appréhender au mieux les
changements de demain c'est ce que nous
souhaitons porter à travers le CNR et
l'ensemble de notre action en ce sens
j'ai notamment engagé des discussions
avec les fédérations représentatives du
secteur dans le cadre d'une réflexion
plus globale intégrant les
problématiques de formation initiale et
continue en santé cette méthode notre
méthode repose sur l'ouverture le
dialogue et la concertation
parce que encore une fois les réponses
doivent être issues des territoires et
co-construites avec l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés vous les
parlementaires les collectivités locales
les associations les entreprises les
professionnels de santé mais aussi avec
les personnes accompagnées c'est avec
vous que nous devons impliquer
l'élaboration de nos politiques
publiques de demain je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
dans la suite du débat chaque orateur
dispose de deux minutes maximum y
compris l'éventuelles répliques le
gouvernement dispose pour répondre d'une
durée équivalente le gouvernement aura
la faculté si le juge nécessaire de
répondre à une réplique pendant une
minute et l'auteur de la question
disposera alors à son tour du droit de
répondre pendant une minute
je donne maintenant la parole à Monsieur
Dominique Théophile pour deux minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 6 octobre est en
France la journée des aidants et ils
sont près de 10 millions dans notre pays
à soutenir au quotidien un proche en
perte d'autonomie cette journée des
aidants m'importe tout particulièrement
car dans mon territoire la Guadeloupe la
tradition de solidarité familiale est
ancrée dans nos valeurs celle-ci
renforçait malheureusement par un taux
d'équipement dans les plus faibles
départements français nous impose de
penser une vision nouvelle dans la prise
en charge des personnes âgées de demain
quel regard porté sur le vieillissement
quelle place donnée aux professionnels
du médico-social et aux proches quel
accompagnement offrir dans nos
territoires
ultramarins trop souvent sous dotés je
me félicite que des pierres successives
viennent solidifier notre politique du
mieux vieillir dans toute sa complexité
je pense notamment au texte visant
mesure d'urgence pour le marché du
travail que nous examinerons
prochainement qui reconnaît la variété
des compétences de projets dans à
travers le dispositif de validation des
acquis de l'expérience
mais l'organisation des soins de demain
nous impose de poursuivre nos efforts
dans le dernier rapport de l'INSEE il
est souligné qu'entre 2020 et 2030 le
nombre de soins senior dépendance âgé de
60 à 74 ans augmenterait de 15% en
Guadeloupe ou de la de 75 ans cette
hausse et de 45%. alors qu'actuellement
seul 5% d'entre eux vivent en
institution que
6695 emplois seraient nécessaires en
2030 pour prendre en charge avec respect
et dignité nos concitoyens âgés quel
collaboration mettre en oeuvre demain
entre citoyens et professionnels du
domaine sanitaire et médico-social pour
assurer une prise en charge adéquate sur
tous nos territoires notamment au sein
de ceux les moins dotés
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
vous avez la parole madame la Présidente
Monsieur sénateur vous rappelez la
tradition de solidarité familiale qui
est ancrée dans les valeurs et
l'organisation de l'accompagnement des
personnes dans votre territoire de
Guadeloupe tout d'abord et
particulièrement ce jeudi 6 octobre
comme je l'ai déjà fait mais comme vous
l'avez fait il nous semble important de
rappeler et de souligner l'engagement
des 11 millions des dents que constitue
notre notre lien social et notre
solidarité familiale le rôle est
précieux pour pour les personnes
qu'elles vivent qu'elles la soutiennent
et qui vivent en établissement ou à
domicile la commande l'accompagnement
des personnes en situation de handicap
et agées à domicile est un enjeu pour
notre société une ambition pour le
gouvernement et ce pour l'ensemble du
territoire c'est dans ce sens que de
nouvelles places seront créées dans les
services de soins infirmiers à domicile
et que le modèle de tarification va
évoluer dans les mois à venir pour mieux
valoriser les prises en soins des
personnes les plus dépendantes
c'est aussi pour améliorer le soin à
domicile qu'un tarif planché à 22 € a
été mis en place pour les interventions
des services d'aide à domicile qui
interviennent dans le cadre de lapin et
la prestation de compensation du
handicap la pcch vous pointez aussi le
manque d'établissement sur votre
territoire pour les personnes qui ne
pourraient ou ne souhaiteraient plus
vivre à domicile un plan d'aide à
l'investissement géré par la CNSA est en
cours ce sont 17 millions d'euros qui
seront destinés au territoire
d'outre-mer et à la Corse dans le cadre
d'un plan de rattrapage vivant la
réhabilitation du parc existant mais
également l'installation de place
nouvelle
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Michel meunier
madame meunier vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues je salue l'initiative de
nos collègues du groupe RDPI et je
saisis l'opportunité d'orienter ses
échanges sur un sujet majeur à mon sens
changer fondamentalement la perception
de ces métiers pour renforcer leur
attractivité cette historique et c'est
culturelle les fonctions du soin souffre
d'avoir été longtemps trop longtemps
naturellement exercée par des femmes
moins un métier qu'une occupation une
inclination personnelle voire une
vocation
ces différentes appréciations rendent
invisibles les compétences exercées la
technicité des gestes la complexité des
relations humaines construites avec les
personnes vulnérables et leurs familles
la valeur de ce travail est clairement
sous-estimée si l'on compare les tâches
professionnelles du prendre soin à
d'autres métiers qui mettent en jeu une
technicité comparable une aisance
relationnelle similaire l'exercice de
responsabilité
l'écart de considération est flagrant et
notamment quand on le compare avec des
métiers à prédominance masculine ce qui
découle de cette sous reconnaissante est
évidente le cumul de faible rémunération
et de temps de travail partiel scindé le
plus souvent subi
rien ne justifie la persistance d'une
telle vision des choses
madame la ministre comment le
gouvernement entendit-il prendre ses
responsabilités pour changer cette
vision dans les métiers merci chers
collègues madame la ministre pour la
réponse
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
je vous remercie très sincèrement de
votre question ces dernières années de
nombreux travaux ont été menés dans le
secteur du grand âge avec un rapport le
rapport du docteur Libaud dont le titre
était changé le regard
changer le regard c'était à la fois
changer le regard que notre société a
sur le vieillissement de la population
mais c'était aussi changer le regard que
nous avons collectivement sur ces
métiers du Caire que l'on appelle pas
d'ailleurs souvent le Caire qu'on
appelle encore les métiers du soin comme
vous l'avez signalé oui nous le savons
tous ces métiers du social du
médico-social sont très féminins je ne
sais pas s'il faut le dire trop mais en
tout cas le constat et ceux qui sont ils
sont féminins une grande campagne de
communication et de sensibilisation
après le covid a été fait une grande
campagne j'allais dire public pour
montrer à quel point l'attractivité de
ces métiers la beauté de ces métiers
dont nous avons besoin dont nous allons
avoir de plus en plus besoin
pour montrer que ces métiers étaient
beaux nous avons une responsabilité
collective après une année 2018 de
mémoire avec un EHPAD bashing nous avons
une responsabilité collective de montrer
que ces métiers sont attractifs ils le
sont parce qu'ils se représente ce sont
des métiers terriblement humain ils le
sont parce que ce sont des métiers
non délocalisables qui sont qui sont
importants et que nous allons avoir dans
les années à venir vous le savez plus
dans plus en plus de personnes à
accompagner et le ministre
Jean-Christophe annoncera aussi une
journée de l'aide à domicile tant ce
secteur aussi nécessite qu'on apporte
une attention toute particulière donc
changer le regard c'est ensemble que
nous y arriverons si madame la ministre
vous avez dit la ministre j'espère que
dans cette enceinte même dans cette
hémicycle nous aurons l'occasion
concrètement travers d'une loi grand âge
et autonomie par exemple de concrétiser
vos propos merci chers collègues la
parole est à Madame Laurence Cohen chers
collègues vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues tout d'abord je
souhaite à mon tour remercier nos
collègues du groupe RDPI d'organiser ce
débat le secteur médico-social est
composé d'une diversité de lieux
d'exercices et de métiers de la petite
enfance à la gériatrie mais tout et tous
vive la même réalité le manque de
reconnaissance de leur métier comment ne
pas évoquer le réseau des CMP tellement
affaibli par le manque de personnel que
les délais pour obtenir un rendez-vous
sont démentiel situation d'ailleurs
identique pour les CMPP c'est structures
conçues comme un lieu d'accueil de soins
centré sur l'enfant actuellement un
quart à un tiers des actes
pédopsychiatriques en ambulatoire sont
effectués en CMPP
or il ne reste que 309 en France quand
on sait les conséquences de la pandémie
sur les enfants et les adolescents il y
a de quoi s'inquiéter ce sera d'ailleurs
l'objet d'un colloque que j'organise au
Sénat lundi madame la ministre nous
sommes face à un abandon institutionnel
de ces professionnels et de fait de leur
passion d'autant qu'en excluant nombre
de ses professionnels des
revalorisations du Ségur de la santé le
sentiment de dévalorisation de leur
métier c'est généralisé malgré les
rattrapages l'an dernier les oubliés du
Ségur existent toujours quant allez vous
revaloriser tous ces métiers de la
deuxième ligne madame la ministre enfin
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
un sujet qui nous tient particulièrement
à coeur avec ma collègue Katia poursu
poli celui des aide à domicile il y
aurait beaucoup par revendiqué mais je
vais centrer mon propos sur le prix de
leur déplacement en voiture qui
s'envolent depuis la crise en Ukraine et
les conséquences sur le prix de
l'essence allez-vous enfin Madame la
Ministre relevez le Baram le barème
kilométrique des aides à domicile de
0,22 euros à 0,35 euros pour leur
permettre de faire face aux difficultés
rencontrées je vous remercie
merci Madame Cohen madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
vous l'avez dit et je ne peux pas
partager votre idée sur le fait que le
manque de reconnaissance des acteurs du
médico-social oui il faut que je regarde
comme votre collègue la précédente
mais je crois que il faut redire et nous
sommes aussi responsables chacun dans
nos propos sur le fait que tous ces
secteurs tous les acteurs du
médico-social doivent être reconnus et
encouragés ça a été vous l'avez signalé
l'un des axes du Ségur nous savons tous
très bien que au fur et à mesure et vous
les avez dit les acteurs du Ségur et les
oubliés du Ségur ont été rattrapés vous
évoquez le sujet des CMP et des CMPP à
travers votre question c'est le sujet de
la prise en charge de la santé mentale
que vous évoquez nous savons très bien
que
j'allais le secteur de la santé mentale
est sans doute l'un des secteurs les
plus
comment dire
mais plus touchés je sais pas si c'est
le terme mais en tout cas c'est sans
doute un secteur dans lequel il y a eu
le moins d'investissement fait ces
dernières années d'ailleurs ça a été un
des premiers plans pas mis en place par
anisme en décembre 2017 un plan de
rattrapage sur le secteur de la santé
mentale la crise sanitaire
malheureusement la crise sanitaire
malheureusement n'a fait qu'aggraver
l'étain de certains de nos concitoyens
notamment chez les jeunes et donc
l'enjeu autour de la prise en charge de
la santé mentale à travers la
reconnaissance des métiers du
médico-social concernant les CMP et CMPP
est importante concernant le secteur de
l'aide à domicile je vous l'ai dit lors
du dernier quinquennat la naissance d'un
tarif socle de vente en tarif plancher
de 22 euros a été une première pour
permettre à toutes les associations de
ces secteurs de pouvoir mieux prendre en
compte les secteurs des aides à domicile
qui est essentiel c'est un secteur dont
nous avons besoin dont nous allons avoir
de plus en plus besoin et qu'il est
nécessaire de prendre en compte
sur le sujet sur le sujet des des
problématiques liées à l'augmentation de
l'essence et du coût de l'essence les
discussions sont en cours avec les
services d'aides à domicile à travers
les ses pommes qui sont les contrats
pluriers d'objectifs pour donner des
dotations globalentaires et de permettre
au service d'aide à domicile
d'accompagner les aides à domicile qui
auraient qui auraient des problématiques
en ce sens
si Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame Cohen merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la ministre je me réjouis
que vous nous appeliez à changer de
regard mais nous n'avons pas les mêmes
responsabilités vous êtes ministre vous
êtes en poste et on attend des actes et
quand vous dites que tout a été rattrapé
bien écouté on ne doit pas rencontrer
les mêmes personnels parce qu'il reste
toujours des oubliés du Ségur quant au
prix de du kilométrage pour les aides à
domicile en creux madame la ministre
vous avez entendu c'est une
revalorisation salariale donc elles ont
besoin alors de grâce arrêtez d'attendre
et donner des moyens humains et
financiers merci
madame Cohen
madame je suis une guidez vous avez la
parole chers collègues madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le secteur du grand âge se
mobilise face à la transition
démographique et la prise en charge
médicale et paramédical des résidents en
EHPAD évoluent ainsi de nouvelles
exigences utiles nécessaires sont venus
modifier la pratique des soignants
coordination des parcours de soins
concertation
pluridisciplinarité démarche qualité etc
alors que les établissements peinent à
recruter des personnels soignants le
marché de l'emploi des secrétaires
médicales des enseignants d'activité
physique adaptée ou des référents
qualités ne présentent pas de fortes
tensions l'apport de ces professionnels
est désormais démontrée notamment leur
présence permet de dégager plus de temps
consacrés au suivi médical des résidents
il est donc temps de mettre en cohérence
le financement des EHPAD avec les
ambitions sociétales de répondre aux
nouveaux besoins des prochaines années
et de donner une impulsion au secteur du
grand âge de demain ainsi l'intégration
de ces professionnels comme éligibles à
un émargement sur forfait soin des EHPAD
permettraient une application durable et
immédiate de mesures favorables
résidents contacts famille coordination
des soins etc et aux équipes soulagement
des professions en tension accroissement
du temps passé aux chevets des résidents
madame la ministre plusieurs ARS
consciente du rôle de ses professionnels
dans la prise en soins attribue aux
EHPAD des crédits ponctuels venant
financer des initiatives dédiées
théoriquement aux expérimentations
secrétaire médicale en Gironde par
exemple ou aux besoins ponctuels
interventions d'enseignants à pas
toutefois ce mode de financement n'est
pas satisfaisant puisqu'il ne permet pas
d'ancrer ces professionnels au
fonctionnement de l'établissement de
manière durable avec mes collègues du
groupe Union centriste je souhaiterais
savoir madame la ministre la position du
Gouvernement sur l'intégration de ses
professionnels à la section soins des
EHPAD pour soutenir les personnels
médicaux et paramédicaux et répondre à
la pénurie de professionnels en tenant
compte de l'émergence de nouvelles
professions au service du soin je vous
remercie merci chers collègues madame la
ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
à travers votre question vous évoquez la
nécessaire prise en compte de la
prévention de la perte de l'autonomie
dans tous les secteurs et notamment dans
les EHPAD vous le savez que l'activité
physique adaptée est un des enjeux et de
nombreux EHPAD ont pu bénéficier de
cette nouvelle façon j'allais dire de
faire de la prévention dans ces dans ce
secteur sur le principe que vous évoquez
sur l'activité physique
d'abord on peut dire qu'elle est
essentielle à tous les âges de la vie ça
tout le monde le sait l'accélération de
son recours est un élément central de la
stratégie du gouvernement qui souhaite
accélérer son intégration sur les
parcours de santé et il a identifié
comme un élément central de prévention
globale et d'amélioration de la qualité
de vie quand on parle du sport santé on
parle aussi de la pratique de l'activité
physique adaptée en ce sens au mois de
mars dernier a été voté la loi visant à
démocratiser le sport en France et
prévoit qu'un référent activité physique
adaptée soit dans tous les
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
donc ce sujet est pris en compte nous y
travaillons merci madame la ministre
vous avez dit du compte pour la réplique
si vous le souhaitez madame guidez alors
je vais faire très rapide voilà je vous
remercie pour votre pour votre réponse
mais l'autre sujet qui est quand même
inquiétant c'est que malheureusement les
infirmières ou les médecins n'ont plus
le temps de s'occuper de leur malade
tellement qu'ils ont des comment dire
des documents à remplir alors que ce
n'est pas leur profession donc il
faudrait peut-être revoir aussi à
simplifier tout ça merci merci chers
collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude
Roquier chers collègues merci
collègue merci de tout d'abord à nos
collègues du groupe RDPI d'avoir proposé
ce débat grâce à la médecine aux
politiques de santé publique nous vivons
de plus en plus longtemps se donne nous
devons évidemment nous réjouir il y a un
siècle seul 4 Français sur 5 sur 10
pardon atteignez-la je le 65 ans
aujourd'hui la France compte un million
500 000 personnes âgées de 85 ans et
plus alors ils ont 2060 elles seront 5
millions et non personne âgées
dépendantes pour atteindre 2 millions
300 000 cette démolition démographique
qui est épidémiologique constitue un
défi majeur pour la société et impose
que nous allions plus loin parmi en
place d'un plat ambitieux pour
accompagner le vieillissement de la
population dans lequel les
professionnels
médico-sociaux joue un rôle essentiel or
ces métiers jour aujourd'hui dit le
pénurie et ne parviennent pas à recruter
à la hauteur des besoins certes il est
indispensable d'améliorer les
rémunérations les conditions de travail
mais aussi les formations avec des
efforts particuliers pour développer
massivement la qualification
d'infirmiers de pratiques avancées qui
contribuent à améliorer la qualité des
soins à réduire la charge de travail des
praticiens actuellement la gélatine ne
fait pas partie du domaine dans lesquels
l'infirmiers en pratique avancée peuvent
pratiquer cette absence de
reconnaissance Fred le développement de
la filière IPA en EHPAD et à domicile
qui apporterait portant véritable valeur
ajoutée sur la qualité des prises en
charge l'organisation des soins et la
valorisation des professionnels cette
reconnaissance d'ailleurs fortement
attendue par le secteur du grand âge
comme le rappelle la société française
de gériatrie et de gérontologie aussi
madame ministre j'aimerais connaître
votre position c'est cette
reconnaissance de la spécificité des
infirmiers en pratique avancées à
gérontologie
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président tout d'abord merci de nous
faire remarquer que nous vivons tous de
plus en plus longtemps et globalement en
bonne santé c'est un point positif et il
faut le souligner merci aussi à travers
votre question de rendre hommage aux
infirmiers et aux infirmières à qui se
mobilisent très fort notamment dans les
EHPAD vous l'avez souligné la pratique
avancée de la partie carrossière
constitue bien l'une des réponses aux
enjeux démographiques médicales et c'est
ce en quoi ces spécialisations ont été
créées elles offrent surtout une réponse
adaptée aux besoins des patients par le
biais de professionnels formés disposant
d'un champ d'exercice très large il
s'agit donc d'une pratique d'une
pratique que le gouvernement entend
développer de façon soutenue nous
travaillons de ce point de vue avec les
universités pour augmenter les capacités
de formation c'est un vrai enjeu et
prévoyons d'enrichir le domaine
d'activité de ces professionnels pour
rendre leur exercice plus attractif
la création d'IPA en gérontologie
puisque c'est votre question nécessite
cependant une réflexion complémentaire
deux écueils doivent être évités d'une
part les IPA pathologies chroniques
peuvent répondre aux besoins de prise en
charge en gérontologie notamment car la
liste des pathologies ciblées par la
mention relève de pathologies dont la
prévalence concerne en particulier les
personnes âgées dans ce cadre certaines
universités ont appuyé leur programme
pédagogique pour répondre à la balance
gérontologique il pourrait être envisagé
éventuellement en adaptant complétant
cette formation et l'intitulé de plus de
façon plus affirmée pour élargir cette
démarche d'autre part nous ne souhaitons
pas multiplier la création de domaines
d'intervention IPA pour chaque
spécialité médicale car l'ambition est
bien une prise en charge populationnelle
spécifique à cet apport en particulier
merci Madame la Ministre très bien alors
la parole est maintenant à madame la
présidente Catherine de roche vous avez
la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre en effet le décloisonnement
entre le médico-social et le médical et
indispensable si on pense au système de
santé globalement alors il existe
au-delà de l'offre binaire concernant le
personnage j'ai une offre binaire EHPAD
ou domicile il est il faut et il existe
des formes maintenant alternatives et
accessibles d'accompagnement dans mon
département j'ai reçu un maire d'une
commune nouvelle qui a un projet très
innovant avec une collaboration entre
deux EHPAD un ssiade avec le domicile
donc ce
projet répond à l'objet des financements
existaient avec le divanum et maintenant
des appels à candidature sont lancés par
l'ARS pour le centre de le centre de
ressources territoriales donc je
souhaitais savoir quel était l'évolution
des financements prévus pour ses centres
parce que concernant la région des Pays
de la Loire c'est 5
financement possible donc un par
département alors qu'initialement
c'était deux donc je voulais savoir s'il
y aura une amélioration des financements
à l'avenir et notamment en 2023 merci
madame la présidente madame les
ministres vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente dans la
Présidente divadom c'est un dispositif
expérimental qui vise à renforcer
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées à
domicile en alternative à l'Ehpad qu'on
l'accompagnement par une aide à domicile
ou une infirmière à domicile ne suffit
plus il faut apporter un complément
d'accompagnement par exemple un
renforcement du temps passé avec la
personne intervention d'une
diététicienne d'une psychologue la
sécurisation du domicile par un
ergothérapeute leur enfance seulement
des interventions la nuit la mesure
votée l'année dernière en LSS 2022 a
créé le cadre juridique pérenne qui
permettra de généraliser les dispositifs
expérimentaux tels que divadom mais
aussi comme les dispositifs renforcés
d'accompagnement à domicile avec un joli
chronique de drade expérimenté au niveau
national depuis 2019 en effet ces
centres de ressources territoriaux qui
sont en cours de déploiement porteront
de manière pérenne une offre
d'accompagnement renforcée à domicile en
alternative à l'Ehpad l'objectif est
bien de donner corps à la promesse du
virage DOM derrière permettre aux
personnes âgées de vieillir chez elle
même lorsque leur niveau de perte
d'autonomie et leurs besoins de soins
augmentent alors qu'on les orienterait
aujourd'hui vers un EHPAD
l'accompagnement renforcé à domicile
permettra à ces personnes de rester chez
elle plus longtemps
évoquer les moyens financiers à louer
avec une enveloppe forfaitaire de 400000
euros par porteur qui peut être soit un
EHPAD soit aussi un secteur du domicile
pour 2022 cette enveloppe était de 20
millions d'euros pour 2023 elle sera de
40 millions d'euros supplémentaires soit
60 millions d'euros au total l'objectif
qui était fixé par Madame bourguignon
alors Ministre chargé de l'autonomie
était d'avoir un maillage territorial de
quatre centres de ressources
territoriaux par territoire aminiva
cette enveloppe poursuivra donc une
croissance constante d'ici 2027 au moins
merci madame la ministre
nous passons à la question de madame
Colette mélo chers collègues vous avez
la parole
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
nous travaillons déjà sur le PLFSS 2023
et que nous sommes confrontés depuis des
années à la difficulté d'accès aux soins
dans nos territoires je veux répéter
l'importance des acteurs du
médico-social partout en France la
demande impersonnelle est croissante
dans ce secteur de nombreuses offres
d'emplois restent vacantes et chaque
jour des personnes vulnérables ne
reçoivent pas les soins nécessaires
notre société nos territoires évoluent
très rapidement les besoins ont changé
la manière d'y répondre également il me
semble essentiel d'avoir une vision
d'ensemble pour répondre aux
problématiques du secteur médico-social
et repenser l'organisation spatiale des
soins de demain de manière globale les
secteurs médico-social paramédical et
médical doivent travailler main dans la
main dans ce cadre la formation et la
clé qu'elle souhaite initiale continue
ou de Recon et cette formation doit être
au plus près des territoires j'en veux
pour preuve en Seine-et-Marne l'antenne
à Melun de l'Université Paris Est
Créteil c'est excellent pour notre
territoire surtout lorsque l'on sait que
les étudiants s'installe généralement où
ils ont étudié ce doit être encouragé et
développer de plus la construction de
Paul de santé sur nos territoires et un
enjeu et il faut savoir qu'ils sont très
souvent associés à des services
médico-sociaux nous devons assurer cela
c'est pourquoi nous devons développer un
panel de formation intégré dans un
système complet équilibré et efficace
qui s'adapte autant aux spécificités de
nos territoires aux évolutions
démographiques sans oublier de valoriser
ces métiers madame la ministre quelles
sont vos pistes de réflexion pour faire
évoluer les formations de ce secteur
merci merci chers collègues madame la
ministre
madame la présidente Madame la sematrice
vous avez raison de rappeler
l'importance et la valeur des acteurs du
médico-social partout en France nous le
dirons jamais suffisamment leur
engagement était particulièrement
remarquable lors de la crise covid-19 et
de leur présence de leur investissement
de leur vocation nous en avons besoin
aujourd'hui et nous le savons ce sera
encore plus vrai demain le président de
la République a affiché des ambitions
claires en la matière à la hauteur des
besoins qui se dessinent je pense
notamment aux 50 000 recrutements
programmés pour renforcer les équipes
dans les EHPAD au cours du quinquennat
alors travailler main dans la main entre
les acteurs du médico-social paramédical
et médical c'est effectivement vous
l'avez souligné une nécessité ce n'est
pas une nouveauté cela demande du temps
et de la méthode un exemple concret des
avancées sur le sujet la mise en place
des dispositifs d'appui à la
coordination qui concernent aussi des
professionnels libéraux ceux du
sanitaire et ceux d'hémoglycosociale ils
vise prioritairement à coordonner les
interventions autour de situations
complexes quel que soit la pathologie et
l'âge de la personne votre interrogation
sur la formation nous la partageons tous
il s'agit bien évidemment d'un axe
essentiel pour améliorer d'une part les
compétences et les connaissances de nos
futurs professionnels et d'autre part
pour améliorer l'attractivité des
métiers et de l'accompagnement du soin
nous priorités car il s'agit d'une
ambition typiquement interministérielle
sont d'améliorer l'accès à la formation
par un effort de simplification mieux
faire connaître nos métiers favoriser
les parcours professionnels notamment
avec la validation des acquis et de
l'expérience il ne vous a pas échappé
qu'hier l'Assemblée nationale a voté en
première lecture la création d'un
véritable service public de la
validation des acquis d'expérience enfin
une réflexion sur les maquettes de
formation et sur leur mise en cohérence
sera également amenée sur ce chantier
comme sur les autres nous n'y appelons
activement
merci Madame la Ministre
la parole est maintenant à Madame
Victoire jasmin chers collègues merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la prise en charge
du cantage et de l'autonomie sont des
enjeux majeurs pour notre société la
reconnaissance et la valorisation de
tous les acteurs du secteur
médico-social rester essentiel en
Guadeloupe il est urgent innové de
repenser les outils à la disposition du
secteur médico-social de façon
différenciée pour chacun des territoires
également mais aussi en corrélation avec
le schéma départemental de l'autonomie
une attention toute particulière doit
être apportée à la formation des
personnels à la mise en oeuvre d'outils
de concertation entre l'État les
collectivités locales ainsi que tous les
acteurs de soins et de l'accompagnement
particulièrement sur mon territoire en
Guadeloupe qui est un archipel
coordonner la prise en charge des
personnes âgées à travers les
dispositifs d'appui à la coordination
les dates dans le cadre des méthodes
d'action pour l'intégration des services
d'aide et de soins dans le champ de
l'autonomie les Mayas en application de
la loi relative à l'organisation et à la
transformation du système de santé il
est important de rétablir une équité
salariale également entre les différents
personnels du secteur médico-social ce
qui provoque des tensions mais aussi des
difficultés de recrutement pour la
plupart des établissements privés à but
non lucratif et particulièrement pour le
secteurs associatifs qui prennent en
charge des personnes en situation de
handicap des personnes âgées mais aussi
dans le cadre de la petite enfance
madame la ministre quelle mesure
entendez-vous prendre pour que nos
différents territoires est des réponses
concrètes merci merci chers collègues
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
madame la sénatrice merci de votre
question concernant particulièrement
votre île de Guadeloupe je l'ai rappelé
tout à l'heure 17,5 millions d'euros
seront consacrés au territoire
d'outre-mer pour organiser un plan de
rattrapage concernant notamment les
places en situation en EHPAD ou pour les
établissements accueillants des
personnes en situation de handicap vous
avez raison vous avez insisté sur la
nécessaire coordination de tous les
professionnels de santé c'est un
j'allais dire c'est un axe majeur mais
je pense que c'est aussi bien de le
répéter de façon j'allais dire régulière
nous avons aussi que c'est la crise
sanitaire qui a permis d'accélérer cette
prise en compte des professionnels pour
la prise en charge du patient il est
important de travailler ensemble entre
le professionnel et de coordonner les
parcours vous avez aussi signalé à
travers deux dispositifs qu'il était
important de lorsque nous créons des
dispositifs de ne pas les empiler mais
que bien il se coordonne et il se
complètent afin de aussi de faciliter la
vie des personnels soignants des
personnels médicaux qui interviennent
autour de la personne sur la
transformation du système de santé
cet enjeu de coordination c'est en jeu
de parcours autour de la personne prise
en charge elle est absolument nécessaire
sous la revolisation la revalorisation
pardon vous savez très bien que c'était
l'enjeu du Ségur que les oubliés du
Ségur ont été rattrapés que les
différences entre les hôpitaux les EHPAD
public les EHPAD privés ont été pris en
compte et que ce différentiel maintenant
n'existe plus nous avons bien conscience
que sur les territoires d'outre-mer
c'est pour ça ce pourquoi le territoire
l'enveloppe de rattrapage existe il nous
reste encore à vous accompagner pour
pouvoir prendre en charge les personnes
en situation de handicap ou les
personnes âgées j'étais à la Réunion il
y a à peu près 15 jours et j'ai bien pu
mesurer à quel point il était important
que nous puissions vous attraper vous
accompagner encore un peu plus
merci madame la ministre
vous avez un temps pour la réplique si
vous voulez
même la ministre je suis pas tout à fait
satisfaite de la réponse parce que les
oubliés du Ségur il y en a encore donc
ça n'a pas été exhaustif donc il y a
encore des personnes qui voudraient
prendre en compte vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
à Monsieur Olivier Hainaut chers
collègues le chant du médico-social est
large on vient de le voir les personnes
handicapées les personnes âgées
l'enfance trois secteurs en manque de
personnel aboutissant à des politiques
publiques essayant de juguler le manque
d'attributivité de ces métiers et pour
répondre à ce manque de vocation les
ajustements sont multiples je pense on
vient de les citer les revendications
salariales du avec le Ségur l'avenant 43
les 183 euros de revalorisation ces
actions de qualité de vie au travail
comme les deux heures de temps social
pour les stades au plfs 2023 c'est une
bonne idée mais qui va payer les
départements sont sont inquiets sur le
plan de la tarification et de la qualité
il y a eu la mise en place d'un tarif
plancher pour les services d'aide à
domicile et des bonus de qualité madame
la ministre avant d'imaginer la place
des acteurs du médico-social dans
l'organisation des soins de demain
encore faudrait-il sécuriser le
périmètre afin que les professionnels
des sad puissent exercer correctement
leur métier qui est de prendre soin et
de trouver du sens à leur activité
professionnelle or le contenu est pas
ainsi le département pour le département
de Nord c'est de la survie même des sacs
dont il est question
leur finance sont fragilisées et l'année
est pourtant loin d'être terminée c'est
pourquoi nous appelons à des
dispositions bordées et soutenables sur
le plan organisationnel nous avons déjà
voté la fusion prochaine des salades et
desiades et nous aimerions avoir un
point d'étape concernant les dispositifs
d'appui et de coordination aussi appelés
DAC le rapport de Dominique Libeau qu'on
a salué est-il mis en oeuvre beaucoup de
questions et singulièrement l'urgence
pour les stades du Nord mais en
conclusion je ferai référence à la
parole des proches aidants ils ont été
beaucoup cités aujourd'hui qui disent
bien que les soins médicaux sont à
laisser aux soignants alors je
renverserai la question quelle place
pour les acteurs du soin dans le
médico-social de demain je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Hainaut madame la
ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur les services d'aide à domicile
les services infirmiers de la domicile
les futurs services d'autonomie à
domicile sont numériques essentielles à
la vie à domicile des personnes en
situation de handicap et âgées vous le
soulignez à juste titre la proposition
faite dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
d'avoir deux heures de convivialité pour
les bénéficiaires de la location
personne disait pour l'autonomie dites à
pas et la nouvelle grille des salaires
permettront de mieux reconnaître les
métiers et l'expérience d'autres
dispositions étaient mis en oeuvre ou
sont prévues pour améliorer la qualité
de l'aide et des soins apportés aux
personnes pour la qualité de vie au
travail des professionnels en assurant
notamment pour les services d'aide à
domicile vous l'avez souligné le tarif
plancher par heure d'aide réalisée dans
le cadre de la location
personnalisée pour l'autonomie de lapin
et la PCH je le rappelle dans ce tarif
est fixé à 22 euros pour les services de
soins infirmiers la réforme tarifaire
prévue par la loi de financement pour la
sécurité sociale pour 2022 est en cours
de travail son application en 2023
permettra de mieux valoriser les siads
qui prennent en soin des personnes très
dépendantes la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 prévoit aussi
une augmentation de ces places anciennes
et il faut le souligner pour les futurs
services d'aide à domicile dit les
sables le forfait coordination déjà en
place sera maintenu pour les futurs
services créer des conditions de travail
d'équipe est un levier complémentaire au
revalorisation salariale pour la qualité
des interventions et la qualité de vie
au travail de ces personnels la mise en
place du service ce territorial de
l'autonomie le SPTA permettra un
parcours plus aisé pour les personnes en
situation de handicap ou agés et leurs
aidants et vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure leur implication nécessaire dans
le cadre de la solidarité familiale
c'est un objectif que nous devons
défendre collectivement ces services
c'est spat devront apporter un lien
entre les structures mais sa mise en
place se fera en respectant et en
s'appuyant territoire par territoire sur
les organisations qui fonctionnent déjà
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à madame Béatrice Gosselin
chers collègues vous avez la parole
madame la ministre
madame madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues en 2050 la France contrat 4
millions de personnes âgées de plus de
85 ans et un contre un million 4
aujourd'hui en Normandie par exemple de
125 000 en 2022 leur nombre passera 250
000 en 2050 une grande partie de ces
acteurs seront en perte d'autonomie et
la place du médico-social dans
l'organisation des soins sera donc de
plus en plus importante avec Luc Ségur
de la santé le gouvernement a prévu
investir autant dans le secteur
médico-social que dans les
établissements de santé pourtant les
structures qui gèrent les personnes
dépendantes âgées ou porteuses du
handicap se trouve souvent en difficulté
malgré le soutien financier très
important des conseils départementaux
tout d'abord ce sont des difficultés de
recrutement face à la déficit
d'attractivité des métiers de l'aide à
la personne une faible rémunération un
manque de reconnaissance de la
profession et des conditions de travail
pénibles et c'est un engrenage car cela
ne permet pas d'assurer insuffisance
des résidents pardon et entretient des
conditions de travail dégradées pour le
personnel ce sont aussi des
augmentations face à l'augmentation des
charges des difficultés
du fonctionnement à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie des denrées alimentaires
des fournitures sans oublier les charges
personnelles
ses coûts supplémentaires impactent la
capacité des établissements pour
investir dans la modernisation du bâti
souvent ancien des EHPAD public et
augmente les tarifs d'hébergement pour
répondre à ces enjeux l'État doit donner
une politique volontariste j'ai deux
questions et d'un administré quelle
mesure le gouvernement entreprendre
rapidement pour se tenir le secteur
médico-social et enfin j'ai cru
comprendre que la loi grand âge économie
verra le jour quand est-ce qu'elle verra
le jour pour enlever toutes ces
disparités et permettre à des gens de
travailler correctement merci merci
chers collègues madame la ministre pour
la réponse
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
tout d'abord le constat pour les métiers
du médico-social que les métiers d'aide
à domicile unanimement perçue comme un
métier utile par 96% de nos concitoyens
mais un métier difficile aussi par 93%
d'entre eux le secteur de l'aide à
domicile reste en 2017 l'activité
professionnelle la plus sinistrogène
pourtant la place de ces professionnels
est essentielle nous l'avons déjà dit
plusieurs fois pour prendre soin de nos
aînés et des personnes en situation de
handicap n'est pas seulement plusieurs
leviers mobilisés par l'étain pour
permettre à ces acteurs au cœur de notre
société parce qu'ils sont indispensables
notamment pour réussir le virage
domiciliaire et vous l'avez fait et
c'est aussi la conseillère
départementale qui veut vous dit il faut
aussi souligner l'engagement des
départements aux côtés de l'étain pour
la prise en charge du secteur d'aide à
domicile
plusieurs leviers sont faits pour
renforcer l'attractivité de ces métiers
et de l'accompagnement du soin à
domicile d'abord l'amélioration des
rémunérations du secteur on l'a pas dit
je crois l'augmentation de 180 euros 3
euros nets mensuels d'ailleurs pour
l'ensemble des agents et salariés des
EHPAD la revalorisation de 15% en
moyenne des professionnels du domicile
la promotion et la qualité de vie au
travail une stratégie nationale qui a
été lancée en 2018 et renforcée en 2020
l'augmentation du nombre de personnes
qualifiées dans le secteur sanitaires et
médico-social avec des places de
formation supplémentaires des
dispositifs de formation courte pour les
demandeurs d'emploi faciliter l'accès
aussi à la formation continue des
professionnels en poste en leur offrant
plus de possibilités de bénéficier de
VAE enfin le développement de Viviers de
recrutement en aidant des employeurs à
recruter notamment avec les vins
plateformes des métiers de l'autonomie
qui facilitent le recrutement des
métiers de l'autonomie et
l'intermédiation au niveau départemental
enfin en faisant découvrir les métiers
du grand âge à deux nouveaux publics
notamment chez les jeunes en leur
proposant des missions de Service
Civique des stages de 3e les demandant
d'emploi en travaillant avec Pôle emploi
pour leur proposer des formations
courtes des contrats et des périodes de
mise en situation professionnelles enfin
les personnes éloignées de l'emploi aux
personnes réfugiées avec des dispositifs
pour faire découvrir les métiers c'est
bien en travaillant sur l'image de ces
métiers que nous arriverons à recruter
massivement les métiers dans une
si madame la ministre il vous reste 15
secondes chers collègues si vous
souhaitez répondre oui madame j'ai bien
entendu mais certains oubliés de Ségur
n'ont pas eu ces primes et pour l'État
vient accorder en 2023 le bouclier
tarifaire énergétique pour les EHPAD
alors que les établissements hébergeants
des personnes handicapées sont exclues
de ce soutien financier madame merci
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
Michel meunier
merci de la présidente madame la
ministre la revalorisation
issue du Ségur de la santé puis décliné
dans le médico-social a conduit au
versement d'une prime par touche
successives après de multiples appels à
considérer les oubliés du Ségur je
poursuis dans la lancée de ma collègue
et pourtant deux ans après la prime
dédiée pour l'hôpital le Ségur est
encore très inégalement inéquitablement
appliquée dans le médico-social là où il
est censé s'appliquer la réalité est
plus confuse et malheureusement il
subsiste encore des invisibles du Ségur
tout l'été les professionnels ont
témoigné de ces injustices notamment les
agents affectés aux missions
administratives ou logistiques dans les
établissements
cette segmentation est injuste et
délétère injuste car les personnels
savent que sur le terrain se
cloisonnement n'a pas lieu d'être un
agent d'accueil en EHPAD est au contact
des résidents et de leur famille un
agent de ménage travaillant dans un
établissement de l'aide à la l'enfance
participe à la mission éducative quand
il s'assure du respect des règles de
propreté
délétère aussi car il indique la porte
de sortie à des personnels formés et
compétents rapidement employables dans
le privé
ces tensions ne dépendent pas que de
l'État certes mais parfois car parfois
des collectivités tardent aussi à
financer leur part de cette
revalorisation mais il est important et
même de votre devoir madame la ministre
d'orchestrer l'entrée en application ma
question est simple le Ségur pour toutes
et tous c'est pour quand si Madame
meunier madame la ministre pour la
réponse
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
vous le savez déjà ce Ségur était de la
part de l'État a donné suite à des
décisions historiques les
revalorisations tentent à l'hôpital que
dans les EHPAD ce sont des reversations
qui n'avaient jamais eu lieu je crois
qu'il est bon de leur appeler et de le
souligner
dans cet or en jeu nécessaire il s'agit
il s'agissait bien d'un rattrapage et
nous en sommes fort conscient
dans le secteur du médico-social et
d'ailleurs si nous constatons qu'il y a
des oubliés du Ségur et quand on
rattrape les Oubliés on découvre de
nouveaux oubliés du Ségur c'est un peu
ceux qui se passe depuis depuis 2020 il
a montré à quel point il était
nécessaire de travailler sur un
véritable enjeu qui nous permettrait de
éviter cet écueil c'est de travailler
sur les conventions collectives uniques
pour les secteurs du médico-social et du
social c'est un vrai enjeu c'est l'enjeu
sur lequel l'État et les dataments sont
en train de travailler qui nous
permettra je l'espère en tout cas à
éviter cet écueil et à éviter dans
l'avenir que il y ait des oubliés et en
tout cas l'État et les départements se
sont engagés à soutenir financièrement
se rapprochement
merci Madame la Ministre cette
parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Philippe mouillé chers collègues merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les pouvoirs publics
incident depuis plusieurs années à la
mise en place d'une médecine de parcours
de santé de soins de vie à même de
renforcer la prise en charge des
patients et des résidences sur tout le
territoire et de décloisonner les
secteurs l'objectif affiché de prévenir
de soigner et d'accompagner de manière
globale et continue des patients et les
résidents au plus près de chez eux cet
objectif suppose une bonne répartition
des structures sanitaires médicaux
sociales et ambulatoire sur le
territoire national mais aussi la
complémentarité efficace des
professionnels de ces structures cet
objectif doit aussi accompagner un
virage domiciliaire qui répond suite
d'une part grandissante de la population
dans ce contexte les acteurs du
médico-social ont donc un rôle à jouer
dans l'organisation de l'offre de soins
et notamment dans l'offre de soi de
demain qui va devoir prendre en compte
le vieillissement de la population
compte tenu des difficultés de
recrutement de secteur médico-social
aujourd'hui des médecins aux aides
soignants cette participation à
l'organisation des soins de demain va
néanmoins supposer de faire bouger les
lignes pour renforcer l'attractivité du
secteur
ma question Madame le Ministre portera
sur l'architecture budgétaire et donc
indirectement sur les moyens les
dépenses relatives aux soins domicile
celle du virage domicilière donc relève
en effet de deux enveloppes différentes
répondant à des logiques de régulation
différentes de ta soignerative pour les
services de soins domicile enveloppe
ouverte pour les actes infirmiers pour
me limiter à ces exemples comment faire
alors pour que cette architecture
institutionnelle ne soit pas un frein à
la participation du médico-social à
l'organisation des soins de demain quels
sont selon vous les conditions à réunir
pour qu'une telle réforme réussisse à
atteindre les objectifs poursuivis je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
madame la ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur
vous l'avez souligné dans vos propos
prévoir accompagner c'est le véritable
enjeu dont nous devons auquel nous nous
appelons tous auquel l'étain s'appelait
avec ses partenaires que sont les
conseils départementaux
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit prévoir
prévenir accompagner se font autour d'un
parcours de prise en charge de la
personne ça nécessite ce parcours
j'allais dire une vision globale des
acteurs et aussi j'allais dire une
vision globale des acteurs sur le
territoire d'ailleurs ça correspond tout
à fait au sujet du jour c'est à la fois
les acteurs du médico-social et
l'organisation territoriale c'est un
vrai un vrai enjeu le virage
domiciliaire d'abord c'est ce que
souhaite 80% de nos concitoyens c'est
pouvoir rester chez eux à domicile le
plus longtemps possible ce virage
domicilien il a été appréhendé lors du
dernier quinquennat avec l'enjeu et la
restructuration des services d'aide à
domicile comme je l'ai déjà évoqué
plusieurs fois mais nous voyons bien que
le virage domiciliaire ne peut pas être
que la seule réponse et que l'enjeu est
bien de trouver j'allais dire un mix de
solution du grand âge et
d'accompagnement l'enjeu du service
d'aide à domicile c'est bien l'enjeu du
modèle économique et nous le savons très
bien il y a à la fois j'allais dire
l'heure de prise en charge c'est pour ça
que nous avons créé un tarif plancher de
22 euros je crois qu'il est important de
le souligner ce tarif plancher de 22 €
n'existait pas il y avait des prises en
charge à travers tout l'été de tous les
départements qui étaient très
inégalitaires et ça c'est un vrai
progrès qui a été voté lors du dernier
quinquennat et lors du dernier PLFSS il
y a eu l'augmentation de 15 euros de 15%
pardon de 15% pour le taux horaire
via l'avenant 43 pour les personnels des
aides à domicile pour elle-même et on
voit bien que l'articulation entre les
services à domicile et les actes
infirmiers ce sont deux domaines
différents l'uniformisation et la
complémentarité est nécessaire à nous
d'inventer les modèles de financement
qui permettent une prise en charge
globale à domicile merci madame la
ministre vous avez 12 secondes chers
collègues si vous le souhaitez
rapidement Madame le Ministre donc à la
fois nous avons entendu le constat vous
tirez le même constat les objectifs mais
concrètement l'architecture est un frein
global à la mise en place d'un service
de qualité et donc on ne pourrons
toujours ajouter des moyens
supplémentaires dédicap pour le Ségur
donc nous réglerons pas le problème de
l'architecture administrative nous
aurons des difficultés permanentes c'est
un point essentiel au-delà même que des
que des budgets aléatoires
complémentaires à mettre en place
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Annie Delmont corropolis chers
collègues
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre chère collègues les acteurs
du médico-social sont divers et variés
en plus des acteurs de l'éducatif nous y
retrouvons des soignants aide-soignants
infirmiers médecins généralistes
psychiatre et des paramédicaux kinés
orthophonistes ergothérapeute
psychologue les dirigeants de ces
structures ont depuis longtemps compris
l'intérêt du maillage territorial et de
la coordination du parcours des
personnes accompagnées par leur
structure le parcours éducatif le
parcours de soins le maillage et le
partenariat les communautés
professionnelles territoriales de santé
médico-sociale pourrait être l'une des
réponses en s'appuyant sur ce secteur
pour renforcer les soins de demain sur
nos territoires il s'agit d'une valeur
ajoutée exponentielle nous pouvons citer
l'exemple de la
CPTs santé médico-sociale
d'Aulnay-sous-Bois porté par une
association
médico-social et qui pourtant répondit
aux missions socle des CPTs et de leur
cadre réglementaire en revanche dans le
contexte du traitement inégalitaire
entre le sanitaire et le médico-social
des revalorisations Ségur et la Forcade
comment compte-t-on nous donner envie à
ce secteur de s'engager dans un nouveau
défi portant sur le soin quelle
reconnaissance du médico-social et quels
moyens pour demain allez vous leur
proposer madame la ministre
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
merci pour votre question et à la fois
merci pour la proposition et l'annonce
de ces CPTs du médico-social
je vais replacer votre votre question
dans le cadre du contexte du CNR très
clairement ce genre d'expérimentation
puisqu'il s'agit il s'agit d'une
expérimentation
mérite d'être posée
d'être peut-être un peu plus accompagné
et l'idée du CNR c'est toutes ces
expérimentations qui fonctionnent c'est
de les laisser j'allais dire pérenne et
de les mettre dans une boîte à outils
qui nous permettrait de pouvoir les
dupliquer sur d'autres territoires et
nul doute que la création de CPTs de la
santé et du médico-social dans un
parcours de prise en charge globale est
à mon sens une bonne idée donc je
viendrais bien voir volontiers comment
ça fonctionne parce que on ne peut pas
parler de décloisonnement et ne pas
imaginer que ce genre que ce genre de
dispositif existe à partir du moment où
ce sont les professionnels eux-mêmes qui
se sont entendus pour le créer moi je
suis intimement convaincu que ce
dispositif ne peut fonctionner que s'il
est créé par les professionnels pour les
professionnels dans le bénéfice de
l'accompagnement de nos concitoyens donc
moi je suis prête à aller venir voir
cette expérimentation et très clairement
dans le cadre du sénère n'hésitez pas à
la mettre en valeur à l'expérimentation
à l'expérimenter pour aller plus loin
dans le modèle du financement parce
qu'on voit bien quand on parle à la fois
de santé et du médico-social on va
s'articuler à une difficulté parce que
vous avez plusieurs acteurs mais si on
trouve la maquette pour le financer et
bah pourquoi pas j'allais dire le maître
j'allais dire dans le droit commun et le
proposer à d'autres territoires c'est
tout l'intérêt du CNR et en tout cas moi
je viendrai bien voir et bien volontiers
voir ce dispositif parce que je crois
que c'est une des réponses à la prise en
charge globale de nos concitoyens
merci Madame la Ministre chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre que je vous invite puisque
c'est mon secteur je suis médecin
coordinateur de ces de ces structures et
puis bon il est quand même important de
rappeler qu'il est primordial de donner
aussi plus de moyens tous les acteurs du
secteur médico-social
si ça peut faire l'objet d'une
expérimentation
c'est parfait c'est à revoir bien sûr
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Annick Pétrus
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues la crise sanitaire
provoquée par le covid-19 et les
nombreux décès en EHPAD ont renforcer la
conviction de nécessaire amélioration de
la prise en charge des personnes âgées
dépendantes elle doit également
permettre d'accroître l'efficience du
soutien à l'autonomie enfin elle est la
promesse d'une solidarité renforcée pour
l'ensemble des citoyens nécessitant un
soutien à l'autonomie ainsi un des
chantiers prioritaire permettant
d'arriver à réel transformation de
l'offre et pour moi le développement des
maisons départementales de l'autonomie
MDA et pour Saint-Martin collectivité
territoriale la MTA à la suite de la
création en 2007 des collectivités de
Saint-Martin Saint-Barthélémy il n'a pas
été créé de maison territoriale des
personnes handicapées une convention
publiée annuelle
existe entre la collectivité et le CNSA
elle a été renouvelée en décembre 2020
pour la période
2021-2024 sans avoir de statut juridique
de MDPH les instances
à la tension des personnes en situation
de handicap la collectivité a recruté
des compétences en interne pour assurer
pleinement les missions d'une MDPH au
sein de la direction de l'autonomie
cette direction était organisée de telle
manière à assurer sa mission auprès de
personnes en situation de handicap mais
aussi en perte d'autonomie à l'instant
de la collectivité de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon mon territoire
doit pouvoir migrer vers le dispositif
MTA rapidement il nécessite une
modification du code de l'action sociale
et des familles comme
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon a pu le faire
par l'ajout de l'article l5318 madame la
ministre ma question est la suivante
l'État est-il prêt à nous accompagner
dans cette évolution que nous réclamons
depuis trop longtemps je
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
l'équité d'accès aux droits pour toutes
les personnes en situation de handicap
et âgées est une nécessité défendue
fermement par le gouvernement c'est
équidé demande de pouvoir décliner les
organisations des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées et services du département
en fonction des territoires on nous
propose pas par exemple un accueil de
proximité de la même façon dans les
Hauts-de-Seine en Haute-Loire en Guyane
ou a fortiori à Saint-Martin la mise en
place d'une maison territoriale de
l'autonomie à Saint-Pierre et Miquelon
dès 2006 résulte d'un choix fort de
cette collectivité d'autres travaux sont
conduits par les collectivités
d'outre-mer telles que prévu dans la loi
du 21 février 2022 relative à la
différence à la décentralisation à la
décentration et portant diverses mesures
de simplification de l'action publique
dès maintenant pour garantir l'équité de
traitement pour les personnes les
professionnels du pôle autonomie de
Saint-Martin peuvent s'appuyer sur les
outils mis à disposition par la CNSA
guide webinaire d'information échange de
bonnes pratiques
on peut saluer le suivi individualisé
personnalisé proposé aux habitants en
situation de handicap ou agés de
Saint-Martin Saint-Barthélémy et
Saint-Péray Miquelon par les équipes des
collectivités qu'il s'agisse d'une
maison territoriale de l'autonomie ou
d'un pôle social je vous invite madame
la signatrice mais c'est un peu ce que
vous avez fait à travers votre question
à ce que les acteurs du territoire
fassent une demande et nous verrons
comment nous pouvons les accompagner
si madame la ministre
je passe maintenant la parole à Monsieur
Hugues sorry pour deux minutes chers
collègues
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues 10000 c'est le nombre de
médecins généralistes que la France a
perdu en seulement 12 ans un tiers de la
population française vit désormais dans
un désert médical et dans le Loiret
comme dans plus de trois quarts de nos
départements la densité médicale a
diminué en 2021 sans surprise la
pyramide des âges des praticiens
incendies un peu plus ce paysage parmi
les propositions récentes notamment
certaines et Manon du Sénat l'extension
du champ des actes médicaux prodigués
par des professionnels du paramédical à
trouver un écho particulier en 2018 avec
la création du métier d'infirmier en
pratique avancée ce dernier rappelons-le
peut désormais savoir confier le suivi
de patients par un médecin dans le
street respect du champ des compétences
médicales pour lequel il a été formé et
diplômé le modèle de cette profession
mérite notre attention il doit pouvoir
nous inspirer pour atténuer les
difficultés que rencontre les acteurs du
médico-social contraint de composer avec
des moyens qualité des revenus souvent
modestes et un système de formation
inadapté la majorité des professionnels
du secteur regrettent de n'être ni
considérés ni reconnu dès lors madame la
ministre votre éclairage est espéré sur
plusieurs points en attendant de
retrouver un nombre de professionnels de
santé en cohérence avec les besoins de
nos concitoyens prévoyez-vous détendre
la délégation de certaines compétences
au professionnel de médico-social si oui
pouvez-vous préciser les actes concernés
enfin quelle mesure comptez-vous prendre
pour accroître l'activité de ces métiers
essentielles et notamment celui des
aides-soignantes je vous remercie merci
chers collègues madame la ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur sénateur
vous m'interrogez sur l'attractivité des
métiers dans le médico-social et vous
avez commencé par parler du nombre de
médecins que nous avons perdu en
quelques années c'est bien parce que
nous avons perdu 10.000 médecins que
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans cette
situation de répondre aux besoins de
santé de nos concitoyens mais la
pyramide des âges n'est pas le sel
facteur pour lequel nous avons une
problématique de médecin nous avons
aussi j'allais dire un facteur sociétal
ou les médecins d'aujourd'hui ne
souhaitent plus tout à fait travailler
comme les médecins il y a quelques
années donc un médecin qui part en
retraite c'est trois médecins qu'il faut
pour le remplacer donc nous partageons
comme je l'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois
aujourd'hui bien évidemment cette
préoccupation et nous avons bien
conscience des fortes tensions de
recrutement existant dans tous les
secteurs du médico-social et du social
les métiers du lien social souffrent
aussi de leur club attractivité afin d'y
répondre et je vais le redire nous avons
déjà mené un nombre important d'actions
l'effort de 4 milliards d'euros en année
pleine pour l'ensemble des
professionnels secteur social et
médico-social a été fait près de 700 000
bénéficiaires d'une revalorisation
équivalente à 183 euros nets mensuels
dont 500 000 au titre du Ségur et de la
mission dite Laforcade et 200 000 suite
aux annonces de la conférence des
métiers du 18 février 2022 qui sont
concernés par ces mesures jamais pareil
investissement n'avait été entrepris
dans ce secteur et je crois qu'il faut
le dire et le redire mon collègue
Jean-Christophe combe a par ailleurs
annoncé le 15 septembre dernier
l'élargissement des mesures prises dans
la fonction publique de revalorisation
du point d'indice aux salariés du
secteur associatif toute profession
confondue cette mesure est sans conteste
une avancée aussi très significative par
ailleurs dans la continuité des
conférences des métiers de
l'accompagnement du social et du
médico-social du 18 février 2022 et pour
accompagner la présence place des
actions concrètes qui ont été annoncées
le comité des métiers sociaux éducatifs
lancés au printemps dernier devra là
aussi faire avancer les chantiers
relatifs à laver à eux et au plan
d'amélioration de la qualité de
[Musique]
pendant ce temps l'hémorragie continue
or ne nous y trompons pas l'avenir de
notre système de soins dépend aussi de
notre capacité à rendre attractif ces
métiers essentiels et à l'utilité
sociale reconnue je vous remercie merci
Monsieur sorry
pour conclure le débat la parole est à
Monsieur Xavier yakovelli pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
madame la présidente madame la ministre
je voudrais en guise de conclusion
saluer la tenue de ce débat au sein de
notre assemblée les propositions
concrètes qui en ressortent témoignent
de l'intérêt que nous parlementaire
législateur portons aux acteurs du
médico-social dont le rôle et cela a été
unanimement rappelé est essentiel auprès
de nos concitoyens les plus fragiles
renforcer l'attractivité améliorer la
coopération notamment à travers les CPTs
et étendu aux professionnels du
médico-social comme la proposer la
sénatrice d'Elmont corropolis et assurer
les galaxies sur tout nos territoires à
ses soins de demain sont d'autant
d'enjeux que de solutions possibles nous
sommes au coeur d'une semaine nationale
des personnes retraitées et personnes
âgées à qui cette année comme thème nous
sommes nous avons indiqué changeons de
regard sur la vieillesse et ce
changement de regard est crucial pour
nos personnes âgées mais je pense que
nous pouvons le souligner comme cela a
été fait lors de nos débats c'est
également changé le regard sur les
métiers du médico-social
le rôle est au cœur de la République et
la crise sanitaire là encore une fois
démontré aux côtés des soignants ils ont
été aux avant-postes mobiliser 24 heures
sur 24 pour maintenir la continuité du
lien Offrir un accompagnement digne à
nos concitoyens les plus vulnérables et
gérer bien souvent des situations
d'urgence cela a été dit ces femmes et
ses hommes sont indispensables
puisqu'ils contribuent au maintien des
liens de solidarité et au développement
de la vie sociale du pays ils sont
présents dans tous les territoires et
dans tous les domaines de l'intervention
sociale ceux du grand âge de la
politique du handicap celui des
personnes en situation de difficultés
sociales et bien sûr celui de la
protection de l'enfance
mais après la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
l'instauration de la sécurité sociale
ces travailleurs sociaux sont intimement
liés à notre histoire ils sont le fer de
lance de notre système de solidarité
nationale au contact direct de nos
concitoyens
ces métiers que nous pourrions qualifier
de vocation éducateurs spécialisé
assistant maternel aide-soignant
éducateur de jeunes enfants ces métiers
sont au cœur de notre modèle social
puisqu'ils ont un impact sur la vie et
sur l'avenir de celles et ceux qu'ils
assistent ce constat est clair et unean
partagé que l'on traite de la protection
de l'enfance du grand âge de la
politique du handicap le secteur du
médico-social souffre il souffre d'un
manque d'attractivité madame la ministre
vous l'avez rappelé d'un manque de
reconnaissance et par conséquent d'une
pénurie alarmante celle-ci a des
conséquences directes bien sûr sur les
travailleurs sociaux puisque leur
mission est entravée mais aussi sur les
publics fragiles concrètement je pense
aux enfants sous protection de notre
institution qui n'ont même plus la
possibilité de se rendre en visite
médiatisée avec leurs parents faute de
professionnels pour les accompagner je
pense aux informations préoccupantes
dont la durée de traitement qui
s'allonge faute de personnel suffisant
peut entraîner des situations
dramatiques pour l'enfant en situation
de danger je pense à l'épuisement des
travailleurs sociaux dans certains
foyers de l'enfance
qui ont pour mission de gérer parfois
seul 40 enfants sous protection et qui
doivent faire l'objet d'une attention
toute particulière nous parents
grands-parents serions incapables de
mener efficacement cette mission dès
lors comment demander à un travailleur
social aussi dévoué soit-il pourrait-il
assumer correctement la mission que nous
lui confions
à cet égard je
souhaite saluer l'action du gouvernement
qui conscient de ses difficultés
décrétera un trop un taux et d'énormes
d'encadrement qui permettront de
soulager les travailleurs sociaux et par
ricochet de mieux protéger les enfants
chers collègues dans tous les centres de
loisirs de nos 36 000 communes de notre
pays nous avons un taux d'encadrement
qui protège les enfants et sécurisent le
personnel périscolaire il apparaît donc
urgent d'établir des règles similaires
dans les foyers de l'enfance alors que
nous savons qu'un enfant sur quatre pris
en charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
est en situation de handicap
la revalorisation historique des métiers
du médico-social qui a décidé le
gouvernement en février dernier et que
nous avons tous soutenu témoigne de la
reconnaissance par l'État du rôle
essentiel des travailleurs sociaux dans
le soin et l'accompagnement de nos
concitoyens les plus vulnérables le
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 qui prévoit près d'un
milliard 5 d'euros supplémentaires pour
le secteur du médico-social apporte
également des solutions concrètes je
pense notamment à l'effort important qui
est fait en faveur de l'attractivité des
métiers de l'autonomie afin de renforcer
la qualité de l'offre d'accompagnement
sur l'ensemble du territoire je pense
également à London qui continuera sa
forte progression en 2023 avec 3,7% or
dépense liées à la crise sanitaire les
mesures prévues par le PLFSS traduisent
notre volonté partagée de bâtir une
société plus inclusive pour nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap à
travers la poursuite de l'investissement
en faveur de la scolarisation des
enfants en situation de handicap et les
mesures spécifiques concernant l'autisme
des troubles du neurones nous le
remarquons sur tous nos territoires ces
professionnels du médico-social ont
toutes leurs parts dans l'organisation
des soins de demain parce que le soin
inclus non seulement le sanitaire mais
également le social parce que accompagné
c'est aussi une manière de soigner pour
conclure je souhaite une nouvelle fois
saluer la tenue de ce débat est remercié
madame la ministre et l'ensemble des
orateurs des groupes pour la qualité de
nos échanges les enjeux nous le savons
sont d'une importance cruciale ils ont
très à notre modèle social à l'égalité
des chances à notre conception de la
solidarité nationale nous devrons les
traiter ensemble durant les mois et les
années à venir et le Sénat chambre des
territoires devra y prendre toute sa
place aux côtés du gouvernement des
acteurs locaux et du monde associatif et
juste préciser le Sénat chambre des
territoires aurait toute sa place
également et ce grandirait à créer une
délégation au droit de l'enfant comme la
peu comme le peu le faire aujourd'hui
l'Assemblée nationale je vous remercie
merci merci monsieur yakovelli mes chers
collègues je vais lever la séance
prochaine séance mardi 11 octobre à
14h30 pour l'examen du projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur la séance est
levée
[Musique]